foreign
[Music]
no no
no no no
no no no no no
no
no no no no
no no
no
[Music]
no no no no no
foreign
[Music]
thank you yeah
foreign
[Music]
bets you guys love playoff edition
though we're talking playoffs I see you
with the Chicago Bulls hat over there in
the uh bowling actually you got the
Bulls head on but I heard you got an
update on some Squad ride on the app
talk to us about it
so Wednesday I had a lot of people
telling me that the Bulls weren't going
to win I was fighting my heart I took a
page out of your book my God just I
didn't think the Bulls were going to win
either but I took the points because I
felt like it was too many and we got the
squad ride done so I saw a couple other
AB community members J Lee and Defcon
said we're on the Bulls so we're back on
them plus five and a half and we're
gonna cash again man I don't think that
the heat got I don't think the heat are
playing good basketball right now so
we'll take the Bulls to keep it close uh
Greg I would like to say you said this
is playoff edition
are we considering are we consider it
the play in the playoffs now
is that what we're doing
technically Ryan it is the postseason it
you know everybody isn't playing in
these games so it's technically is it is
the postseason you know I don't know
about that I feel like if I if you bet a
team to make the playoffs to play the
play-in wouldn't have cashed your bet
that actually is true because I got I
got cooked on my Nets to miss the
playoffs bet uh early on when the
turmoil was going on I should have bet
the maps everyone went and bet the maps
to win the title I should have known
Kyrie would have was gonna burn that
down
you do have a point
but at the same time I would say it's
the postseason I would say it's supposed
to okay but
with all that being said we are back I
feel it feels so good to be back welcome
to the show everybody my name is Greg
Ivory to your left
is the man we like to call producer Ryan
uh We're not gonna give him any
nicknames today we're just gonna keep it
strictly producer Ryan okay and this is
Ryan as a nickname you're we're going
it's done it together Greg it is a
nickname but at this point it's like
it's so common it's regular now it might
as well be my legal name yeah it's my
government name
let's go let's go let's go make it
official let's go make it official uh to
you guys is right
you got the man of the app the legend
himself I call him MB you might call him
Michael Bolin but we got the legend the
Chicago Legend here you see how I beefed
up mb's intro and then I just left Ryan
it feels so good to be back honestly I
missed you guys this is this is The
Vibes I needed to I wish I could say the
same bowling I wish I could say this
hey drop your Best Bets for tonight's
playing games in the chat we're talking
Bulls heat Thunders T wolves Ryan what
are the people talking about well facts
lab just said producer Ryan Crossing
salmon and Greg today I did feel that
way I did feel that way in the first two
minutes I was like damn I gotta I gotta
take it easy
um T Harris 22 dropped a rat uh truck 23
shy over pra I don't know what the nut
you got to give me the number but uh
that's the later game I don't know if
you guys want to start with with Bulls
heat or if we just want to if we want to
follow the vibes
I think we start with Bulls heat
honestly I mean it's the first game of
the day
and you know I'm excited
me trying to get those Bulls [__]
hey I feel it you already know that's
how I'm coming and beat I'm rocking for
the home soil so yeah man let's talk
Bulls he we might as well jump into it
all right so I see
lvae says over one and a half Steals and
blocks for Caruso
this is an interesting I mean like if
you if you enjoy watching defense
defensive players he had himself a damn
game against the Raptors he was all over
the place blocked steals
Ryan I know you got to pull it up are we
able to to add those into the uh into
the parlay so we can't we can't do
um
blocks
there it is
either or
I kind of like that man
I actually I mean I mean I'm I'm so down
with what you guys were just talking
about but my focus was more so on the
Chicago Bulls and Michael bowling's hat
also his shirt also The Vibes also the
connectivity that's leading me to
Chicago Bulls plus five and is it five
and a half or five
five and a half yes sir
I think we should stay away from the
squad
say yes you think so
I think so I is Ryan talking or is he
just like being a mime right now I can't
hear him but his hands are moving you
can't hear me at all
I can't no I can't tell if he's being a
producer or if he's being producer Ryan
I don't I can't tell the difference
right now like can we not put this into
the the parlay or is that just like
Orion pushing his agenda type thing can
you not hear not hear me I can hear you
now all right they tried to they tried
they tried to silence
no no no no no I want to keep this out
of that I want to keep the squad right
out of the Parlor
I just have to clarify this is that like
a a
producer Ryan saying that trying to push
his narrative or is that Ryan the
producer that works for Bleacher Report
actually being a producer
no no no that's me saying that's gonna
lose so I'd prefer to not put it in
there so let's put it on oh my god so
let's put it again
what we're staring at Alex Caruso one
plus steals at minus 430. you just said
he puts on a defensive Clinic
he does he does I'm
so all right so take the minus 430 and
then add the Chicago Bulls plus five and
a half why actually buy some points if
we need to because bro I think I I think
they might win outright
definitely do
I agree I'll just say that I also see I
also see in the chat argonzo he's saying
Levine over four assists in the last
let's see the last five against the Heat
he's had seven seven two four and four
that seems like a pretty good number if
we want to if we want to add another
little quick leg Levine played the best
game of his life or maybe not his life
but the best game as a Bull against the
Raptors and went absolutely crazy I
think their wing Defenders are better
than the Heats are so
I think I'm expecting another big game
from him and that will include him
having over four assists so I kind of
like that play Shout out to argonzo uh
also shout out to D geek who said stop
hating on producer Ryan there are people
who there are people who who love me all
right hold on first off deep geek is an
original VR betting app fan he's been
here since yesterday
so he's a real one so you trust his
opinion hold on hold on D geek hasn't
been around in months so I don't even
think he knows who you are Ryan
it's better for me that's better for me
so D geek thank you for tuning in you're
gonna get accustomed to my man Ryan up
there
he's definitely one of a kind uh so so
we added the Alex Caruso uh one steal in
there
and we're not gonna add the Chicago
Bulls plus five and a half I just like
let's think of it let's just think of it
this way if if plus five and a half gets
and I know we have other stuff to get to
but if plus five and a half gets cooked
then the squad ride is cooked and the
parlay is cooked are we trying to hinge
everything into one thing
like I know I said I think Miami covers
but
that's I don't know that was more me
trying to like actually just shoot you
away from Bulls plus five and a half
[Laughter]
I feel you sometimes you just gotta go
with the Vibes you know what I'm saying
sometimes you got to read the energy
Vibes incorrect wavelength incorrect
we've been going for we've been going
with Vibes for the better part of two
months now I can't genuinely this is
this is an honest take I can't remember
the last time we won I really can't
it's because of your agenda right
the only the only reason why I would say
leave it off potentially is because we
could definitely win both of them
separately and double our cash we don't
have to have the side and the parlay but
you know me I think the Bulls are going
to win this game out right I'm taking
the points because I want to be safe
because I've broken my heart before but
you're not gonna get me to say I don't
want it in there I think the Bulls are
going to win so I'm with Greg
I mean we could take you yeah we could
take more points if we're worried about
the number
um I mean I yeah that's what I'm saying
hey hey MB you're on to something you're
on something if I'm worried about the
number
I mean we got a minus 430 in there
boost it up boost it up let's go I was
really hoping I was really hoping our
guy my guy Darian would jump in here
because he had uh Kobe white over one
and a half threes and you know I like
that too but if I say it it's my agenda
and then you know Greg's gonna be like
did he did hey Darian actually say that
are you pushing it you know then it's
gonna get it's a whole big thing
deep geek is in the chat sag I'm
starting to understand the hate a
producer Ryan exactly it's a point it
took what three minutes
[Laughter]
okay that's good you like eight and a
half
all right you like it I love it
love it I really want you to go over
there to the plus money down there right
down there
what's up
Ryan I I did see the the Darion 85 play
so I can confirm and I also love the
play on Kobe the last five games against
the Heat he had four threes two two and
or last four games four three two and
three
he's been getting more minutes he's
playing better
I'm I was told it was plus money I hope
it still is so if you can go down there
and check it out because I think my man
Kobe's gonna have a pretty good game
against the Heat so then can I propose
something and darian's in here now what
up Darien
um I what if we keep the Bulls plus
eight and a half and then add Kobe
White's threes and take out Caruso are
we because I kind of want to even I'm
down for that I'm done go two in the
early game two in the late game
yep yeah still plus 102. all right let's
do that
uh oh plus 191. uh we could possibly add
more points if we wanted to we could get
it to 10 points plus ten let's go to the
other game and then uh and then we could
see what we want to maneuver around a
little bit here
um all right so we were talking off we
were talking off camera and we aren't
sure why the number is what it is but I
absolutely love the thunder tonight love
them they're just a super fun team to
bet they play to the last whistle
they're all young and they're playing
with house money imagine thinking you're
not gonna have Chet Holmgren in the
beginning of the season
and they still find a way to make them
play in this team's gonna go pretty nice
for a while
after after what day did the was that
Tuesday was that Tuesday that the the
Lakers took on the Timberwolves yep yeah
after Tuesday I'm so I'm so used to I
made a tick tock in in in Instagram that
you guys probably saw uh I was talking
about after last night I can't say that
anymore because you know it's been a
couple days but after Tuesday the
Minnesota Timberwolves being the
favorite by five points after Tuesday
that's just absurd that's a that's
absolutely the way they played that game
that is absurd yeah and I literally
tricked that game off and Rudy Rudy
being back like we had said before the
show bowling I I don't necessarily know
if that's a good thing for Minnesota
exactly so if we want to take we could
also buy points with with OKC if we
wanted to but I'm down I'm down to take
OKC on the spread uh Darian seems to
love it Rob dog22 my guy what's up uh
said Thunder went outright we'll play it
safe and take some points here
plus it's already the plus 400 range so
we we have a lot of room to play with
here
um
my bad MB go ahead no I was gonna say if
we act if we can identify a lucky play
within like a player prop we could
probably get both of these spreads to
like nine or ten and still be close to
like plus 400. you know who's you know
who's got one right
who's got it
come on stop it you're asking don't ask
questions don't ask silly questions I
got it baby I gave it stats all right
let's go over to player rebounds
Josh giddy Josh Giddy and His Four games
that he's played against Minnesota this
year 13 rebounds 12 rebounds two
rebounds but forget that I said that at
11 rebounds
13 12 11.
the two doesn't count the two is a
mulligan great it's like when you're
teeing off and you hit one into the
woods why would he say two but don't
listen to that one but don't listen
forget I said that that's what I said
it's a mulligan you hit it into the
trees and you're like that didn't happen
put another ball down that's it
my question is Ryan my question is I
like the play I actually do like to play
Josh giddy he's like he he
you know flirting with triple doubles
game game the game you know what I'm
saying so I like the play but but what
number are we gonna do are we sitting at
this are we looking at this nine and a
half or are we gonna like you know do
what we do best and we're going to six
we're going to six because that's six
that's three cheese that's fine
minus 900.
I mean look at this how does this lose
how does this lose losing I don't see it
losing bro in all honesty this parlay is
pretty lucky the way it is but yeah but
you guys like to do what y'all do best
yeah okay let's buy some points is like
let's buy some points so we don't get
locked in or we don't get trapped if
they you know we we have to take the
hook obviously so we don't end up losing
on a tie
yeah I mean man
this is this this is the thing that I
think I definitely have a lot of money
riding on the Bulls winning tonight
but I also am going to start putting a
lot of money on the Thunder because
everything I think about man Minnesota
absolutely sold at the last game they
were winning and they were in control
and they just started turning the ball
over the one thing I will say is Anthony
Edwards cannot possibly play worse than
he did last game there's no that is true
yes it would be very hard one for eight
two for 18 or something in the game like
he's gonna play better but I do think
the Rudy go bear coming back after the
punch of the teammate whatever
I don't know if they're gonna all be
able to be on the same page so I like
okay uh I will say yeah it was like a it
was like a uh he wouldn't he didn't
really swing at him it was like it was
like I want to swing but I don't really
want to swing so let me just do
something to make me look I didn't like
that I didn't like that he's 7-2 and
just immediately started backing up I
didn't love that but you shouldn't be
fighting teammates anyway bro I'm
talking about backing all the way up
like he was like all the way in the
parking lot yeah
all right where are we at Ryan we got A
plus 424
how many points did we buy Ryan uh we
bought two I wasn't able to buy three it
just didn't get us where we needed to be
uh elbow I want to address I want to
address his comments real quick keeps
telling us to take Josh Getty's pra
for months now we have addressed that we
can't add Pras it's the same game
partless that's just tough we can't do
that it is tough because El base I do
like but I do like that as a play so I
do encourage people to I mean Josh giddy
like Greg said
he's he's basically flirts with a triple
double each night that's the kind of guy
you want to bet the Pras on for sure
yeah exactly are we locking this one in
or okay yeah four legs we got four right
there
sure there's one more time for the
people yeah and we we adjusted it so the
the well uh we'll uh update the the
graphic there in a second but it's uh
Bulls plus eight and a half Kobe white
over one and a half made threes
uh Josh giddy six plus rebounds and the
Oklahoma City Thunder plus seven and a
half that's plus four fifteen
tell us on FanDuel I believe it's this
little bonus bet uh promo they got going
on four legs plus 400
um win or lose you got a Bonus bet
depending on how much you bet so uh I
would go opt into that and and when when
we win you have a little bit of a free
money to play with as well so yes sir
when we win there it is when if you want
if you guys want to tell our four leg
parlay make sure you head on over to
FanDuel and opt into the NBA same game
parlay promo for a bonus bet if it loses
the Free Bet
money
yes sir all right let's build a series
Winner's parlay Ryan
are the comments saying anything
interesting are they talking about
Series winners uh because uh
I know who's winning one Series in
particular
yeah who's that first of all yeah let's
relax who's that
Golden State Warriors because I've been
waiting for this moment for at least
that's going to be easy that's going to
be easy that's like
the fact that the Warriors are playing
the Kings and Ryan the fact that you
have money on the Kings after repeatedly
disrespecting Sacramento disrespecting
Mike Brown disrespecting the Aaron Fox
and sabonis in that Sacramento Kings
team and the fan base there now you're
rocking with them how weird is that how
weird it's not weird Greg it's not weird
because this is the same guy who put on
a front and was rooting for a football
team that he slandered all season but I
love the fact that we started this show
and we got all the way to the end and we
got a match up that forced Ryan to go
against his heart I love it I love it so
much I would like I would just like it
known that I'm 1-0 in bets against teams
that I've slandered for an entire year
what's your what's your team's record
the ones that you actually like yeah
thank you thank you thank you are we
talking about that bowling I don't think
we I don't think we mentioned the Boston
Celtics on here I'm just
I'm sure we'll get there right I just
wanted to tee you up maybe okay all
right let's let's start knocking these
let's start knocking these series uh
these series uh odds I'll uh let's take
a look at this first one Nick's
Cavaliers we'll talk we'll talk Warriors
we'll talk Celtics when we get there but
who we got in this one Nick's Cavaliers
who do you guys like
uh D geek likes the Knicks and then
uh so does call me extra doubt says
Nick's over Cavs uh a fresh says Nixon
six here's the thing I don't have the
time to click on each one of their
little profiles and see if they're
located in New York but all these little
rats in New York yeah right all these
little rats in New York are convinced
that the blue and orange are somehow
gonna take down the Cavs who for the
most part have been good throughout the
entire year
um really good yeah yeah so
I
I think if the cat I don't I think if
the Cavs are going to lose this series
it'll be in a game seven I don't think
they do
um so we could take the plus one and a
half we could take them straight up at
minus 205. if you guys are really
confident in the Cavs we could take the
minus uh one and a half like what do you
guys want to do here
I would say just to be safe I mean we
gotta get we got to be safe and the safe
play is take the Cavs straight up I
don't think the Knicks are any good bro
I really don't
I I don't either
I think they stink I like that one I
think if it goes seven if it goes seven
it's in Cleveland yeah
all right Brooklyn Nets Philadelphia
76ers uh
are we just taking the Sixers straight
up and moving on all right let's do it I
mean I mean you could I'm gonna be hey
should we do like Sixers minus one and a
half or you know I like that better I
mean I don't see any way that the Nets
win this series they just started
playing together and JoJo's been on a
mission all year I like the one and a
half get us some value at least I yeah I
agree I don't think there's any way this
gets to a game seven either so it's a
way better number minus 310. so let's do
it yeah yeah all right let's move on all
right we got Clippers Sons this one's
very interesting very interesting you
like the Suns Ryan I mean
the thing I think this goes like seven I
think this one goes seven yes at least
six
I think this is either two edited
competitive series
I think I would feel better about the
Clippers beating the Suns if they had PG
but Kawhi is just a different boost in
the playoffs he kind of he kind of just
like takes over games takes over series
you saw what he did back when they beat
uh uh the Sixers when he was on the
Raptors like I don't think this is gonna
be uh a quick series I agree with Greg I
think this is going at least six or
seven but my lean is to the Suns just
because they're missing uh Paul George
yeah I I also like Katie has lost two
games since November that's not even
that two games isn't even enough to
eliminate you from a playoff series so I
think we just take the Suns here we
don't mess around with any numbers
um all right the one that we've all been
waiting for all right here we go all
right let me let me let me get my take
off because I'm gonna get out of the way
I want to set the stage for you guys
Ryan I'm really disappointed in you
after taking all that all your
opportunities to slander Sacramento I
wish we were going to one of the games
and it's going to be really nice to hear
to have Greg kind of dunk on You by the
time this is over because I don't see a
way that the Kings get out of the series
The Kings have been a really fun story
all year I love the light the beam I was
one of the people saying Sacramento is
probably a pretty fun place to go hang
out watch a game
but the Warriors are battle tested
they're healthy they're gonna win the
series
come on ease
go bro
I already have my
monster so what do you have to say
the Warriors
and and I I say this with Statistics
backing me
cannot win on the road
they refused to so to me if we wanted to
just play around with this I while I
think Sacramento actually wins this
series because I think people are
overlooking them and I I over you know
admittedly overlooked them for seven
months and as a city
you admitted something yeah listen as a
as a city more I'm not gonna actually I
shouldn't say city as a town I you know
it's not a place I would necessarily go
to
that was a mistake that was a mistake
that was that was decided way too long
ago they need to revisit that it was a
mistake the village of Sacramento
the township of Sacramento yeah the
neighborhood of Sacramento uh that's so
funny they're good they have the home
court advantage here and I know what
Greg's gonna say is that this is a home
game yeah this is a home game for the
Warriors
listen listen listen
I think we take Sacramento plus two and
a half in the series to just compromise
because I there is no chance that it the
Warriors that this series doesn't at
least go to six in my opinion the
Warriors are not winning two games on
the road
no Greg can you tell my friend producer
Ryan that this is a gentleman's sweep
series
come on and be
bad on the road okay Ryan well let me
tell you this the Warriors own Northern
California so you talk about this being
a road game for them
watch tomorrow when that game turns on
you're going to see the blue and gold
filling up that Arena out there in
Sacramento more than those kings fans
and I'll tell you that much so
it might technically be a road game but
the Warriors players they're sleeping in
their own beds
there's they're going to be loud Golden
State Warriors fans up in Sacramento
they're taking bus rides up to
Sacramento no planes I thought they were
nowhere near each other Greg I thought I
I thought San Francisco and Sacramento
were nowhere near each other
that's what those are words that came
out of your mouth
what you said you never said that if if
if I said that technically they're like
about 70 75 miles away so if we're being
tested that's a quick lyric that's a
quick clear jet no no no no no keep it
in their own beds that's an hour and a
half commute
all right let me let's lock in the
Warriors Ryan I already did I already
did I'm not winning that battle go go
let's move on let's speed let's go let's
go fast let's go fast through these last
ones because um
I gotta get up out of here y'all I'm
gonna be honest I gotta make my bets I
gotta go run down to the casino and put
these bets in before these games come on
so let's speed through this Lakers
Grizzlies I like Grizzlies
I I like Lakers plus one and a half
yeah they're not gonna go outside
I was gonna say I don't think LeBron's
going outside I think it's gonna be a
close series I'll take the lake uh
Lakers plus one and a half I'm concerned
we haven't taken an underdog yet I will
just I'm gonna put that out there that's
okay we're taking games if you pick the
Grizzlies to win but it's okay let's you
take let's take Lakers plus one and a
half and let's move on to the next one
ah I mean the Celtics and Hawks I
originally
what's up you can't see it did you move
the screen we can't yeah there's a
little bit of a delay going on here okay
uh I Celtics
Celtics
yeah
minus two and a half
yep we like it
yeah okay I mean I kind of agree
no they really might sweep they really
my sweet no the whole yeah is that the
last one yeah that was the last one and
let's just be let's be honest here real
quick the Hawks suck Dave like they
stink stink so
stick so read it read it off so I can
find out the I need your fastest
fastest you've ever read off a bed slip
right now let's go you got it uh
Cleveland Cavaliers minus 205 in the
money line of that series Philadelphia
76ers minus one and a half alternate
series handicap against the Brooklyn
Nets Phoenix Suns minus 500 money line
against the Clippers
Golden State Warriors minus 275 this
might we might get cooked on this I'll
be honest with you we might get cooked
uh and then the Lakers plus one and a
half uh I guess the Memphis Grizzlies
and then the Boston Celtics minus two
and a half against the Atlanta Hawks and
Trey Young's uh farewell Series in
Atlanta
you guys can do is screenshot screenshot
it get it in your phone so after this
show you guys can go go to fan go go put
it in yourself just just go put it in
yourself you're welcome thank us later
uh let's Get on Up out of here guys I
think it's time to get on up out of here
and I gotta go put these bets in so both
questions
go ahead and be
I would just say both plus five and a
half I'm going to the United Center
watch party
check out the social app coming up
that is one of the games that we will be
riding I'm rocking with you and be uh
but yeah let's get on the party here
because I really gotta go place these
bets so for me for Greg Ivory Michael
Bolin producer Ryan we are out of here
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]